parts of hey long xiam Province are
submerged after storms brought by
typhoon doxori pummeled Northeast China
record rainfall is causing rivers to
break their Banks flooding entire
districts and damaging roads and bridges
in neighboring ji Lim Province
helicopters are being used to rescue
people trapped in villages authorities
in China say more than one and a half
million people have been moved to safety
we received notice that the flood was
cresting on the river early on Friday
morning so we began to organize the
relocation of affected residents at 4am
all the affected residents have been
transferred and resettled now
this is the fifth typhoon to hit China
this year doxori swept through the
southern province of fujian affecting
more than 2 million people causing
damage worth more than two billion
dollars before hitting Inland Beijing
hey long Xiang is one of China's biggest
grain producing regions authorities have
sent soldiers to help affected areas
we've spared no efforts to support the
local emergency rescue and disaster
relief efforts we've restored
communication services in 16 towns and
267 Villages that were out of contact
repaired 98 kilometers of damaged roads
evacuated nearly 13 000 residents and
sent 500 tons of relief supplies and
medicines to them
it's a similar situation in Taiwan where
some mountainous areas are flooded heavy
rain and floods aren't unusual in the
region at this time of year the typhoon
season generally lasts from May to
October but with more extreme weather
patterns that scientists attribute to
climate change scenes like this could
become a lot more frequent
Victoria gate and B Al Jazeera